j'accueille ophélie winter
oui
le retour de sprinteurs voilà ça va
monsieur va très bien et que c'est moi
qui les fais comment c'est ophélie
première émission de télé premières
couvertures de magazines voilà alors
leur tour d'ophélie winter c'est sur m6
music black reçoit je regarde toute la
journée ils étaient à chien favori avec
une émission intitulée mission mi6 mèche
mais si ça passe le mardi à 21h pendant
dix semaines alors au départ c'est une
émission américaine dont vous assurez
ophélie des plateaux français
vous avez tourné les plateaux à miami
dans la maison de gianni versace très
sympa j'imagine mais sympa il manquait
un petit peu mais c'était très beau
cette maison est hallucinante
il ya madonna qui est venu pendant le
tournage qui est venu voir les
contestant les commandes a amené les
les compétiteurs gfr le pitch de cette
émission donc le résumé c'est treize
jeunes rappeurs qui rivalisent pour
empocher 100 mille dollars enregistrés
et enregistrer un album avec missy
elliott
voilà c'est une espèce de star ac
version rap us way sont en cours ouais
c'est pas de cours ils sont et son brut
de décoffrage et les met dans un bus et
vas-y en avant guingamp sur une émission
itinérante dans un autobus laurent